christian valérie patrick le vcc va les
régler
christian frédéric françois
bonjour je suis bien contente de vous
voir vous devriez aller là-bas françois
s'amuse bien
non j'étais droit l'intérieur du pied
voilà à toi un peu plus vite
valérie qu'à ton frère allez vite à
matonge de la balle en jeu europe était
restée un agric au soir plus on regarde
ça va tu accompagnes voilà c'est ça
quand ils apprennent sur le tas est là
c'est bien pour les faits invoqués par
thomson comme ça tienne regardez là pour
ça voilà l'un des jeux stupides et puis
mon épouse par ici stop stop et ben
d'idéaux casimir sa première liste de
noms jjj un grave problème à résoudre
et il faut que vous m'aidiez tous eh
bien on a été saisi mais bon ils ont
convenu avec moi on est installé vous
dites mais à côté de moi on va dire
casimir bon alors qu'est-ce qu'il va ta
cuisine mais tu tiens pas à poser de
questions je vous demande simplement de
m'aider voilà bodineau faut pas
d'ignorer comme ça qu'est ce qui va
sortir
voilà j'ai des chapeaux ici mais voilà
alors je voudrais savoir comment
s'appellent celui ci alors attendez
voilà on va poser la question a atteint
delphine dard commença de chapeau
chinois chinois un chapeau chinois
oui j'ai beau chinois et s'agace à la
presse c'est une note
bon tu te mets sur la tête et d'une dans
quel pays ça vient
ça vient de chine évidemment j'étais au
chesnay et les uns et celui là bon
attendent autant faut pas bousculer
kazinian bon alors c'est ça quand on est
sur le ballon là qu'est ce que c'est que
ce chapeau voyant
christian ce chapeau là que ce serait je
vois bien que c'est drôle mais ça vient
d'amérique
à quelle époque empress javaux de
l'armée l'armée sudiste ou nordiste
c'est pas un mot non plus les amis la
famille là aussi pour ça c'est difficile
mais on va demander à sophie sophie
gachet couture qu un chat couture queen
s'agit croissant qui a été en turquie
ah non tu connais pas bien que tenait
sur la tête encore une autre encore
et puis il apprend le brand la wet est
pas mal qu'est ce qu'un chapeau frédéric
deck 8 mai le château
qu'est ce que tu as dans laquelle sont
attachés aux mexicains un chapeau
mexicain ça doit être ça et ça a rien eu
d'abord du mexique voilà je mets sur le
fc bâle je prends savoir quel est le
plus beau que sakho quel est le plus
beau chapeau leurs attentes en attendant
ils sont tous beaux mais c'est vrai
alors voyons dû tourner sonauto ah oui
toi delphine séparés c'est la montre
tourne mon expo schaefer voilà frédéric
bâtisse et c'est pas facile ils sont
tous très jeunes femmes ont choisi
celui-là allez on choisit celui là tu te
prête à quasiment jamais c'est vraiment
là leur plus beau chapeau
c'est le plus beau non c'est le plus
beau rêve mais c'est le plus beau kring
si le faire
je crois qu'il a perdu et bien vous
m'avez rendu un très grand service bis
dont casimir du peut nous expliquer ce
qui vient de se passer
oui et oui voilà quoi là et bien avant
de venir
j'étais en train de faire un château de
cartes
lorsque j'ai éternuer ah voilà et ton
château est tombé oui alors le château
est tombé avec la table sur laquelle ils
étaient posées et puis comme la table
était devant une fenêtre fermée tous les
cas rond point était cassé et une volée
ont été arrachées voilà le lundi dans
casimir nous manque du temps du patron
sous l'eau mais quel est le rapport avec
les châteaux et bien voilà lorsque je
suis en colère
le meilleur moyen de calmer la colère
c'est de piétiner h
un chapeau alors lorsque je suis très en
colère il me faut un très beau chapeau
pas la sécu orapa émises par tap
ouah ouah